رحله اوكرانيا الى الناتو يبدو انها طويله
وقد لا تتحقق مجله فرن بوليس الامريكيه
تقول انه لن تتم دعوه اوكرانيا للانضمام
الى القمه السنويه للحلف الشهر المقبل
المقرر اقامتها في ليتوانيا والتي سيعلن
فيها القاده التزاماتهم طويله الاجل تجاه
البلد المضطرب
بحسب المجله قد يطول ضم اوكرانيا في
التحالف الذي يوفر لها ربما الفرصه
الوحيده لتفادي الهجمات الروسيه
المستقبليه على سيادتها بدلا من ذلك يضع
حلفاء اوكرانيا ضمانات امنيه بعيده كل
البعد عما تعتقد كيف انها بحاجه اليه حذر
واضح من قبل الناتو وبعض دول البلطيق في
قرار ضم اوكرانيا للحلف حيث انه بحسب
المجله الامريكيه هم يخشون المشاركه
بالحرب الى جانب القوات الاوكرانيه بموجب
الماده الخامسه التي تعتبر الهجوم على
احدهم هجوما على جميع الاعضاء وتلزم كل
دوله بحمل السلاح دفاعا عن دوله اخرى عدا
عن مخاوف من تصعيد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين واستخدام انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الناتو كمبرر لما يمكن ان يتصاعد الى هجوم
النووي وهو ما يتفاهه الحلف تجنبا لاي
تصعيد الولايات المتحده والمانيا تقولان
ان التركيز يجب ان يكون على الحرب
المستمره بدلا من هجوم روسيا مستقبلي في
حين ان دول شرقي ووسط اوروبا تضغط من اجل
خطه متماسكه لضم اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو
وضمانات الامنيه ملزمه بدلا من ضمانات
بدعم عسكري اكثر قليلا مما هو مقدم حاليا
بولندا العضو في الحلف مستعده للذهاب ابعد
من ذلك بارسال قوات الى اوكرانيا اذا لم
يتم تقديم ضمانات امنيه كبيره لاوكرانيا
في قمه ليتوانيا
تدافع دول الناتو عن نفسها من خلال
التاكيد على انها ملتزمه بالوعد الذي
قطعته في بوخاريست عام 2008 وعود قد لا
تتحقق بالنسبه لكييف كونها بعيده عن عضويه
الحلف حتى الان وربما في المستقبل المنظور
ايضا بحسب ما خلصت اليه المجله رش خياط
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات